INSTRUCTOR: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to the content and
video for tree data structure,
OK.
So now that we've covered the
list-like data structures,
like lists, arrays,
queues and stacks,
we're going to talk about trees.
So tree data structures
provide some optimization
with a lot of the operations
you do in a data structure,
putting data inside there,
finding it, deleting it.
And those operations can be
done a lot faster in a tree
than they can in a
list data structure.
And to demonstrate that
or illustrate that,
let's bring back up the
example of a phone book.
So in a phone book, since
everything's sorted,
recall that you can find
something in log n time or log
base 2n because 2 being every
time you open up the phone book
in half, you've removed half of
the phone book that needs to be
searched again.
So if you just keep
searching in halves,
half, half, half, half,
half, the number of page
turns it takes you to find
something in a phone book
is log base 2 of n.
So the idea with
the tree structure
is, let's take advantage of that
log n ability in a find, insert,
and delete opposed to the log--
excuse me, opposed
to order n of a
find, insert, and
delete in a list.
So that's what we're after
is the speed of log n, OK.
So let's take a look at
some tree structures here.
First, the bulk of what
we're going to talk about
is a binary search tree, a BST.
But to set that up, let's
have just a quick look
at a binary tree.
So a binary tree, as
you can see right here,
a binary tree has nodes
and then children.
They're also referred
to as inner nodes,
if they're inside the
tree or leaf nodes
if they're at the edge of a
tree and have no children,
that's a leaf node.
And then there's the
root node, if you
can see where my mouse is
hovering right now at the top
here.
Number one is the root node
or the beginning of the tree.
All these inside nodes or inner
nodes and then these leaf nodes
are at the end here, OK.
So this is a binary tree.
But so what the heck are nodes
or what do they represent?
They're the exact same thing as
whatever you stored in the list.
So if you have a list of
floats, the tree version of that
would just be a node
containing a float.
So just like we don't really
call spaces in a list nodes,
but that's really
just all they are.
So a space inside a list.
For example, you start counting
at index 0 in a list, here,
you would start at
the root of the tree.
But that's really all they are,
just a space to store data.
And as you can see, though,
they have a different structure.
Instead of one node next
to another, like a list,
here, there's a child
relationship, a parent
and child relationship.
So the root is the parent
of all the other nodes.
And then you can see,
it's got two children.
Hence, the name binary,
refers to two children.
So the left child is node
two and the right child
is node three, OK.
So that's the rule
of a binary tree.
And again, why do we care?
It's because we want to
get to where we have find,
insert, and delete
operations in log n time
much faster than order n time.
All right, so now, let's add
one little piece to this.
So binary tree, in
practice really, I've
never used a binary
tree in my life.
I've used binary search trees,
a specific type of binary tree
often.
So here's the one rule we add
to a binary tree to make it
a binary search tree.
Here's the rule.
That every child on the left
has to be smaller than the node.
And every child on the right
has to be greater than the node.
So let's start with
the root node here, 8.
So if the root node is
8, everything on the left
must be smaller.
Well, is 3, 1, 6, 4, and
7 all smaller than 8?
Yes.
On the right side, is 10, 14,
and 13 all smaller than 8?
Yes, they all are.
So this binary
search tree follows
that rule of everything
on the left smaller.
And you can see all of the
inner nodes follow that as well.
Look at this 3.
Everything on the left
of the 3, 1 is smaller.
Everything on the right of the
3, 6, 4, 7 is greater than.
And that's true for all
of the nodes in the tree.
So that's a binary search tree.
And a binary search
tree, that's where
you start to get the phone
book ability, the ability to
divide the data in half.
So when I look for
something, say, I'm
looking for the number 6 here,
well, if I start at the root 8,
I know 6 is less than
8, go to the left.
Then I get to the node
with a value 3, OK,
6 is greater than
3, go to the right.
And then I go to the right here.
So it's like that phone.
Like I divide--
I'm dividing my tree
in half each time,
looking for what
I want because I
know I don't need to search
that half of the tree
at all, if it's not
what I'm looking for.
So that's what
gives us that order
log n speed of a binary
search tree, all right.
So let's do some
examples here, OK.
So I'm going to take these
nodes here and do some--
insert them into a tree.
So I'll start with 3.
These are the nodes here,
3, 1, 4, 1, 5, 9, 2, 6.
And I'm going to insert
them into a tree.
So first, we have the root 3.
1, we go to the left.
Add 1 there.
4, we insert, go
to the right there.
1 is a duplicate.
There's a couple of ways
to handle duplicates.
In practice, you can either
have a counter on each node
and then just
increment the counter
and say, hey, there's
a duplicate one,
just add a counter.
So count would be 1 here already
and you make it counter 2.
Or in practice, you
can just add it.
If you make a rule, just
add duplicates to the left.
That's fine too.
And I'm going to do that here.
So 1 gets added there.
5, we start at the root,
we go to the right.
5 is greater than 3,
5 is greater than 4.
As soon as we hit an
empty, we insert it.
In fact, maybe I
should point out here,
if we have a leaf node here,
it still has two children,
it's just that they're null.
They're empty values.
And that'll come into play when
we write the code for this.
When we hit a null value,
that's when we know,
OK, this is where I'm going
to insert my node, all right.
So next up, we have a 9.
We start from the root,
9 is greater than 3,
9 is greater than 4,
9 is greater than 5.
And we insert a 9.
2 is less than 3.
2 is greater than 1.
2 is inserted right there.
6 is greater than 3, greater
than 4, greater than 5,
less than 9.
And here's our binary
search tree, OK.
So then when we
want to do a find,
let's say we do a find of
5, a find of 5 here, OK.
We start at the root
5 is greater than 3
and greater than 4,
and then we hit the 5.
So as soon as we find
this, we return true.
We return true.
And that return true goes
back to the 4, back to the 3,
and then is returned to the find
5 function call as true, OK.
So when is it not true?
What will be the case
when we cannot find the 5?
Well, it's actually as
simple as when we hit a null.
So for example, what if
we did a find 7 here.
7 does not exist in the tree.
We start at root, go to the
right, 7 is greater than 4,
7 is greater than 5, 7 is less
than 9, 7 is greater than 6,
and we hit a null.
I'll even add 1.
There we go.
Then I'll add 2.
We hit a null.
Well, null then,
we return false.
So this return false is returned
back up to 6, 9, 5, 4, 3.
And then find 7 is true.
Excuse me, find 7 is false, OK.
So I need to point out
one concept that I've
been glossing over quickly.
The operations in a tree can
be performed recursively.
So recall from our
definition of recursion,
a recursive problem
is when the logic
to solve the superset
of the problem
is the same as the logic to
solve the subset of the problem.
OK, that's a wordy
explanation, but it's actually
a really practical example here.
So when I take this tree,
when I'm looking for 7,
the logic on how to get it,
if the tree is this size,
is the exact same as if the
tree is only 4 and then down.
So the logic I start up
here, 3, I go to the right,
it's the exact same
logic all the way down.
Go to the left, go to the
right, go to the left,
go to the right. go down,
go down, go down, go down,
hit a null 7.
Well, in recursion, what
stops the recursion?
The base case.
So in my base case, I'm going
to be looking for either I
found my number in
the case of find 5,
my base case is going to
look for the number I found,
or it's going to
look for a null.
So those are my base
cases and the operations
of a binary search
tree for the find.
Did I find what I'm looking
for or did I hit a null?
Then those base cases return.
In the case of find 5,
it's going to hit the 5
and return true,
return true, return
true to the original function
call, and then you're done.
That's recursion.
Same thing with the find 7.
I make a function call,
function call, function call,
function call.
Hit a null, base case
triggers, return false,
return false, false,
false, false, false, false.
Recursively find 7,
function call returns false.
So trees are also a perfect
candidate for recursion.
And you'll find that when you
do these operations recursively,
it actually makes the code
very small and concise.
Because remember, the logic
to do this on a tree of size 1
is the same exact logic to
do it of size 1 million.
You don't need more for
loops and while loops
and if statements to handle
a tree of size 1 million,
it's the same exact logic
if it's the tree of size 1.
So once you get your recursive
function, which is just
a few lines of code for
the find and the insert,
it works no matter
what size the tree is.
So it makes it a perfect
candidate for recursion
and the recursive solution
a lot more simple, OK.
Last thing we'll cover here
on the board is delete.
So now, let's say we're
going to delete this 5,
there's one caveat you need
to keep in mind when you do.
In fact, I'm going to--
I'm going to change
on the fly here.
Let's do a 10.
And then we'll do--
let's do another
10 because we're
following the rule duplicates.
Go to the left and then 11, OK.
I'm adding this really
quick here to 2.
There's one caveat you have to
keep in mind with the delete.
And I'm adding a
little bit of the tree,
so I can show you that.
OK, so now, we're going
to delete the 9, OK.
So we're going to delete the 9.
Well, to delete the 9,
first we have to find it.
So a delete is
identical to a find.
It's just that once
you find it, you
need to delete it
out of the tree
and adjust the tree so it's
still a binary search tree, OK.
So first step in the delete
is find it, 3, 4, 5, 9,
we found it.
So can we just delete
it and call it good?
Well, no, we can't
have a binary search
tree that just has something
missing in the middle.
It just has a non-existent node.
We need to readjust this
tree, so that it's still
a valid binary search tree.
So how do we do that?
Well, what are our options here?
We could bring up the 6 here.
And then would that
still be valid?
6 is greater than 5 and
10 is greater than 6.
Yeah, that would work.
But I added this to show you
one problem that can arise.
If this tree right here,
if the next layer is full,
can we bring this 10 up?
No, because 10 has
two children already.
So if we bring
this 10 up, 6 would
become the left child of 10.
Well, 10 already has a left
child and a right child.
And you can't have three
children in a binary search
tree.
So what do we do to--
so this 6 doesn't have children.
But what if it did?
What if this 6 tree
was full right here
and this 10 tree
was full right here?
Well, we'd have to make
a rule of something
to bring up to become
the new member,
to become this new node here.
And there's two
options you can do.
You can either find the
max in the left tree.
So let's see, let me just
add a max really quick here.
So let's say that was a 9,
this is going to be a 7, OK.
We can either find the max in
our left tree, so bring 7 up.
And the structure is intact.
And the reason we can find
the max, if we have a max,
it means there's no right child.
There's no right child,
if that's the maximum.
So then we can
bring it up, and it
won't hurt any--
it won't mess up
the structure of adding any new
right children because it never
had a right child.
Let me restate that a
little more clearly.
If I find the max
on my left subtree,
it will not have a right child
because that right child would
be greater than, and
that would be the max.
So the max does not have a right
child, we can bring that up.
And then any right
child that did
exist can just become the
new right child of that node.
And then the structure
of the BST is maintained.
And that works great.
The other option,
you may have guessed,
we can either bring up the
max in the left subtree
or the minimum in
the right subtree.
Because the same idea, the
minimum in the right subtree
will not have a left child.
So in this case,
our minimum is 10.
Bring up this 10, it does
not have a left subchild.
So any left subtree that
this deleted node had,
we can simply attach to
it as its new left subtree
because we know it
didn't have any,
if it came up as the max
node in the right subtree.
So we bring that node up,
it becomes the new node.
And then the structure of the
BST has remained in place, OK.
So that is why binary
search trees are used today
because it's a way, a simple way
to have a data structure that
gets you find,
inserts, and deletes
in order log n time, all right.
To conclude this video, I'm
going to show you one more thing
here.
So we've talked about structure.
We've talked about the
point of a binary search
tree is to get order log
n findings or deletes.
This might be a new
data structure to you,
but it's actually used
pretty heavily in the world.
And now, you know what
a binary search tree is,
you might notice it more or
see where it's a better data
structure for.
But just as a fun
example, I put into GPT,
what are some examples
of BST in use today?
And it gave me binary search
trees or widely used data
structures.
Databases, many database systems
use BST to store and retrieve
data efficiently.
Well, how is it stored
and retrieved efficiently?
It's stored and
retrieved efficiently
with order log n time.
Log n is way faster
than order n time.
So database is a great fit.
File systems are a
great uses for trees.
And you can see that.
If you're using a Mac OS X
operating system or a Linux
operating system,
the root directory
is the root node of the tree.
So that's a direct comparison.
Windows is a little bit
different, Windows uses drives.
But just think of those drives
like mini roots themselves
or multiple tree structure.
But all of the big three
operating systems, Mac OS X,
Linux, and Windows all use
binary search trees, OK.
Also, symbol tables
or just network
routing and spell checkers,
there's language models.
There's a lot of uses
for binary search trees
because they get you the
speed of entering data, OK.
That is a overview of
binary search trees.
Thanks for watching.